I am under the English Channel on the
train in one of the wonders of the
modern world the channel tongue and it's
easy to take a tunnel for granted these
days you just buy a ticket take you
somewhat ridiculous leopard prints in
case it's not mine
on board the train and a couple of hours
later you're in Paris and it's easy to
forget just what a wonder this thing is
and it's easy to forget it was 200 years
nearly from the first proposal to put a
train under the English Channel was the
train back then it would have been
horse-drawn carriages lit by oil lamps
to this wonderful construction under the
seabed itself and here is something you
might not know those older steams those
somewhat ridiculous Victorian schemes
some of them actually started in 1881
exploratory tunnels were made about a
mile out from the UK and a help from
France there was a tunnel started but
then the British press and politicians
got cold feet and thoughts might
compromise on national security and in
the 1970s the British government of the
time was all for building a tunnel but
then they got cold feet when the economy
tanked but just imagine we might have
had a Channel Tunnel a century earlier
if it hadn't been for Britain being
worried about its sovereignty although
given there was World War two and Hitler
really could have been faded through it
perhaps they're onto the right idea that
is something you might not
you